Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson
is proposing a different explanation to
the Mike Pence classified document
situation and Tucker Carlson's
Theory really a hypothesis but sometimes
we say Theory colloquially is that Mike
Pence just happened to find these
documents at his house right now because
Pence is in cahoots with the justice
department under Merrick Garland's
leadership to take attention away from
what Joe Biden did and to try to screw
Donald Trump we are really learning a
lot about propaganda this week from
Tucker Carlson you might remember on
yesterday's show we had a segment about
the floating space vagina you and I
would call it a cloud because that's
what it was but Tucker Carlson found it
extraordinarily disturbing that was an
instructive view into right-wing
fear-mongering today it's conspiracy
theories here's what Tucker Carlson had
to say he said that a few times
then just days ago Mike Pence sent his
personal attorney to search his family's
home in Carmel Indiana for classified
documents
now if Mike Pence didn't think he had
classified documents why would he send
his lawyer to go look for classified
documents hmm we can't say for certain
but it's entirely possible in fact it's
likely that Mike Pence was asked to do
this by federal prosecutors who are
trying to build a case against his old
boss Donald whoa now the point would be
to show that not every federal official
walks off with State Secrets Donald
Trump was uniquely evil in that regard
as in so many others and again he's
minimizing the fact that the Trump
situation is so dramatically different
than the Biden or Pence situations
stole versus misplaced refused to give
back versus immediately turned over used
lawyers to prevent returning the
documents versus used lawyers to
immediately return the documents but
Tucker doesn't want you to think about
any of those differences Mike Pence
didn't do it
so if that was the plan and we suspect
that it was right it backfired
spectacularly because Mike Pence's
lawyer promptly discovered classified
documents uh-oh he immediately loaded
these documents into his car and drove
them back to Washington to hand them
over to authorities Mike Pence mean yeah
so you know one of the things about most
of these conspiracy theories is that
they are either unfalsifiable or
unlikely to ever be proven or disproven
and that fact becomes part of the
conspiracy theory let me explain what I
mean by that Tucker Carlson says you
know what this could have been
this could have been the justice
department
uh recruiting Mike Pence in order to
help build a stronger case against Trump
so they said go have your lawyer look
for documents your lawyer certainly
won't find any and then our case that
what Trump did is uniquely bad will be a
stronger case now of course there is no
evidence whatsoever of that and it is
unlikely that there is ever going to be
evidence of that the most reasonable
explanation for why there won't be
evidence of that is because Tucker
Carlson made it up but the way that
Tucker Carlson and his followers
interpret these types of unfalsifiable
conspiracy theories is that when there
is no confirmation one way or the other
because again there's no evidence it's
sort of like if you said to me David can
you give me proof that you don't own a
Lexus
and I would say to you well it's hard to
prove a negative but I mean I can show
you the car I do have and I can show you
the insurance for the car I have and
you'll see it's not a Lexus and then you
could go well it's not really proof you
don't have a Lexus you also might have
registered it under someone else or you
might have it stored in a different
garage how can I prove a negative and
for a lot of these conspiracy theories
the way it will go is remember Tucker
proposed that thing that the justice
department was working with Pence and he
never really was able to disprove it
well right but no proof was found that
that was going on yeah but it's very
suspicious that they weren't able to
clear themselves of that well but how do
you prove a negative it's the exact same
mechanism the other uh and this is
common conspiracy theories are often
based on at least some premises that
can't be disproven and and what that
leads to is whether or not the theory is
true the people who follow it have no
way to verify its authenticity and that
becomes part of the problem so another
clinic from Tucker Carlson on how this
stuff works and remember his audience is
uniquely suited to be targeted by this
type of stuff and when it comes to in
court
Fox News lawyers are quick to remind uh
um uh courts that Tucker Carlson is not
a news person
he's doing entertainment using Hyperbole
and nothing he says should be taken as
literally the truth because he's not
doing news but he does a segment like
this and all of a sudden a huge portion
of his followers believe well that
sounds right it sounds like this was
Pence and Cahoots with the justice
department there is no such evidence
we'll take take a quick break we'll be
back after this with just a packed
program today one of our sponsors today
is Bluetooth a unique online service
delivering the same active ingredients
as Viagra and Cialis in a chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost and
they're giving my audience an entire
month's supply for free so if you think
you could benefit from an extra boost of
confidence when it's time all you have
to do is take a short quiz on their
website a licensed doctor approves your
prescription the medication comes
straight to your home within days in a
discrete package and no driving around
to the doctor's office or the pharmacy
no waiting around no awkward
conversations with your doctor all of
Bluetooth tablets are made in the USA
the entire process is just a few clicks
go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping